I'm gonna try something a bit different
today I wanted to do a like a gameplay
video for a long time but I've always
been worried that my computer which is a
laptop and really old wouldn't be able
to handle it the gaming and the screen
recording which is still sort of the
case I still have a first really old
laptop but I figure I'll try and do a
short video either that or I'll go until
my computer catches fire whichever comes
first so this is a game called universe
sandbox and it's kind of right up my
alley
I haven't played it extensively before
I've just had a little look at it so I'm
probably four years late to the party on
this game but it still seems really cool
so
here we've got a solar system in real
time so the simulation is going one
simulated second for every real second
that passes so nothing really looks like
it's moving too much you can see we've
got the planets Jupiter looks like a bit
of a smudge let's see if we can go over
there oh yes so that's all of Jupiter's
moons I guess that's why it looks so
crazy let's see if we can get Jupiter
itself so many moons I can't get it
there we go okay so I know she's not
sure how the physics are going to be in
this game I've heard they're a little
bit dodgy I've seen already that there
is slightly dodgy with a few things I
know they don't do relativity so all the
physics are sort of Newtonian
but maybe they do an okay job of gravity
let's see what we can do okay so one
thing I want to try as I know you can
send a light pulse which means you're
sending out a sphere of I guess photo
representing the light that's coming off
an object and seeing if that light
travels how far it's traveling in sort
of what some space it's taking up so
we'll set a sphere of particles
okay let's first set this back to one
wheel second set a sphere of particles
there they are radiating out from the
Sun so these are all our photons here
and they're coming for us so you might
have heard it takes light about eight
minutes to get from the Sun to earth and
that's because the lights traveling at a
certain speed although they're traveling
at the speed of light which is extremely
fast and it's still finite so it takes a
finite amount of time for the light to
reach us I guess if I run this
simulation for eight or so minutes we'll
see the time that it takes looks like
it's already about to get to mercury I
find this concept pretty interesting
because it's like I don't know it kind
of represents the sphere of things that
we know at least about the Sun and
anything sort of inside of that sphere I
guess we we don't know about it's the
idea that the Sun might have disappeared
already and and we wouldn't even see it
disappear from our sky for the full
eight minutes it's like this is the
knowledge and everything else is just
dark to us
see if we can speed this up
so it looks like the lights about to
reach us over here now see if I can pose
it when it gets to us okay so it's have
a look at her
[Music]
okay so I guess it's hard to see there's
the sphere of particles this whole thing
sort of reminds me of I don't know if
any of you guys have done like or
studied astrophysics but one of the
common questions they ask you to do in
sort of exams and stuff is work out
questions regarding the intensity of
light coming from the Sun and they might
say something like the Sun emits a
certain power and what intensity of
light is is hitting the Earth's surface
given that power is being emitted and
the way you do it is you take that power
and you work out how much intensity per
square meter is on the surface of the
sphere of light emanating from the Sun
and then you knowing the sort of surface
area of Earth can work out the intensity
that reaches Earth it's sort of I know
it's a question you do a lot in class
and this is a cool representation of it
alright wonder
the other cool thing when you think
about it takes us 8 minutes to notice
that the Sun is missing in the sky is
that it would also take us a while to
him
gravitationally noticed so let's see if
we can delete to this son
can we get rid of the light pulse I
don't know what I deleted that's making
you one all right we've got this pulse
of light coming out from the Sun and
after that was emitted we took that Sun
and deleted it so it and flights still
going to travel to us even though that
Sun is no longer there it should also
start to affect the orbits of some of
these planets as the main mass they're
orbiting around is no longer there I
wonder if we will be able to notice that
perhaps let's speed things up
okay so many years have passed and I
guess everyone looks a little lost here
because the Sun is gone they haven't
moved very much also interestingly it
was take a look at the earth it's still
lit on one side how curious I think if
the Lighting's not as realistic but yeah
that light sources no over there
so that's the Scylla system without the
Sun let's take a look at something else
okay I've wiped everything and now we've
got a nice blank slate here to work with
with this nice set of stars in the
background so I want to see if we can
make a pulsar a pulsar is sort of a
highly magnetized rotating neutron star
or I think it can be a white dwarf as
well so let's get such a star this is a
serious baby this is a white dwarf let's
chuck that out there
okay
nice so I want to look at its properties
so I'd like to make this white dwarf
quite highly magnetized
magnetic field Gauss let's go with Tina
to the power of 12
[Music]
okay that should be quite a lot let's
give ourselves a pole angle
can they nice just give ourselves some
rotations he'll have rotations tiny
effects
I guess let's go to speed
actually no rotational period that
sounds alright 0.2 seconds
okay it's going somewhere let's see now
that's pretty cool that's cool that's
kind of what the artisan impression of
pulsars look like so a pulsar basically
is kind of like a lighthouse in
astronomy you get signals from these
sort of jets that are putting out
electromagnetic radiation and you get
the signals from them on quite a
reliable period because they're rotating
like this there was a bit of I guess
controversies surrounding the discovery
of pulsars and that they were first
noticed by a PhD student Jocelyn Bell
Burnell and she was the first one to
notice them and pick up their strange
sort of signals and the discovery of
pulsars went on to be enough to win a
Nobel Prize
however the Nobel Prize went to Jocelyn
supervisor and not to her
and I think that was a bit of sort of
outcry about that that it wasn't fair
that she should miss out but it was
justified I guess by that her supervisor
as the head of the research group was
able to take responsibility for both the
good discoveries and anything they did
wrong which I don't think is
particularly fair but it's just what
happened in this case
I was lucky enough to actually meet
joseline and when she visited my old you
need to do a series of talks about
astronomy and about her life in physics
and she's really interesting a really
good speaker and a really smart woman
and so I think it's a shame she missed
out on the Nobel Prize but she's gone on
to have a really good career in physics
it's hello look at another one of these
simulations I've got sort of pre-made in
here
galaxy collisions I think that would be
interesting
about 4 billion years from now our Milky
Way galaxy will collide with the nearby
Andromeda galaxy this collision the
result of the mutual gravitational
attraction between the stars planets and
other matter
that make up both galaxies will produce
a single merged galaxy it is unlikely
that any stars in the galaxies will
actually collide although some styles
will likely be ejected from the combined
galaxies during the merge well let's
have a look at that
okay the scale is pretty high we've got
like 70,000 years per second this is the
Milky Way and at the top we've got
Andromeda and so yeah they're just
spiraling toward each other and this is
eventually gonna happen to us
let's just put on pause
we're in one of the spiral arms of the
Milky Way that's our home and and I
guess there we are with millions of
other stars
I think what that little description
said was the fact that even though it's
such a dense clump of stars and there
are so many the distance between stars
and between planets is so vast that even
in this sort of crossover region where
the galaxies are like merging together
it looks less like a blur now but
individual stars aren't banging into
each other they're just like passing
through each other I think that's pretty
cool let's just see if we can zoom back
out continue to play this I think one of
the coolest things about I guess when
this happens not that I'd be around to
see it but is that our night sky would
change you would look up and the at the
stars at night and not just see the
stars and our galaxy but also see all of
these other stars as the galaxies
collide and I think that would be an
amazing sight the night sky would
probably be pretty bright actually to
have all these stars so close
I mean you can actually see the
Andromeda galaxy in the night sky maybe
with the naked eye now it's just sort of
a very small fuzz of light and you'd
probably need to know where to look for
it but
you can you can see Andromeda you can
also see at least in the southern
hemisphere definitely with the naked eye
they're quite obvious as the Magellanic
Clouds which are two little dwarf
galaxies and I think that's pretty cool
that not only at night do we see the
stars in our neighborhood but we can
actually see into other neighborhoods at
the moment okay so this is our swelling
this I wonder if it will settle down to
become like sort of a regular shaped
spiral galaxy or what its final shape
that's going to be it's been on a casual
hundred and seven billion years really
amazing so far actually seems pretty
fast don't know how much longer it would
take to kind of reach a bit of an
equilibrium
delete can drop it
I guess we could
I know the description see them some
stars would also be ejected from just
like a little crazy gravity that's
pulling things this way in that in this
miniature and I guess some of these
little clumps
maybe those ones out there look like
they may be getting ejected it's kind of
hard to resolve only a few styles on
here such a mess
so this is Andromeda it's got a black
hole at the center I guess we can remove
oh that seems to have had an effect
yes
almost like an antigravity effect things
are now without that black hole in the
center of Andromeda there's nothing to
attract things back into the middle and
we've just had a splat on our galaxy
mixtures okay that's pretty cool
Wow okay can we get rid of Andromeda now
yes and this is what is left of the
Milky Way after not only our collision
but the removal of that black hole we've
kind of gotten hundreds of little
clusters I wonder what will happen to
the end of now
find something new to attract too
I mean I've only just scratched the
surface of things you can do on this
game I know there's so much more I can
do I can like throw objects and other
objects you know throw a son and the
other son throw a son in here or there
much difference on the scale
yeah following the Sun but that
assessment
yeah if if you guys have any suggestions
or would like me to see me play any of
any more of this game let me know let me
know what things you'd like to see
and I'll see if they're possible on the
game so thanks for watching hope you
have a good day